in the last video we divided 100 into
ninety-nine point zero six one and we
did it the manual way we did it the long
division way in this video I just want
to show you a quick shortcut because
we're dividing something by a power of
10 if I have if I have ninety-nine point
zero six one if I multiply by a power of
ten I'm going to make the number bigger
every time I multiply by 10 the decimal
would shift to the right by one spot so
99 point 0 so we could say 99 point zero
six one times 10 is going to be equal to
990 point six one notice we just moved
the decimal over to the right by one if
I were to do I'll just arbitrarily
switch colors 99 point zero 6 1 divided
by 10 we're going to shift the decimal
in the other direction this is going to
be nine point nine zero six one so when
we divide by 100 we're dividing by 10
twice we're shifting to the left twice
so if we start with 9999 point point
zero six one divided by a hundred let me
just write it like this we've already
written the problem if we want to divide
this by 100 moving it one spot to the
left will divide it by ten we'll divide
it by 10 and then moving it 1 another
spot to the left we'll divide it by 10
again so this will be so 999 point zero
6 1 divided by 100 is going to be equal
to 0.99 zero six one we're just going to
shift the decimal to the left by two and
we might want to put a leading zero here
just so it makes it a little bit easier
to read